Let's look at the solution to our BTB and
BHT quiz. This time the question was how many
times do we access the BTB for each of
these instructions. We have a perfect BHT and a
perfect BTB. The BTB has four entries, the BHT
has 16 entries. This doesn't really matter in this
part of the quiz. What you ned to know is that when you have both the bhd and
the btb, the btb is accessed only if the bhd says that this is a taken branch.
If this is not a taken branch, then we can just increment the pc. Because
this instruction is not a taken branch. And
because the BHT has perfect prediction, the BTB
will never be accessed. Same thing here. And
now I can tell, that for all non-branch instructions,
we will just have zero BTB accesses, because they are never predicted to be
taken branches. This branch here is executed
100 times and is always taken, so here
the BTB will be accessed 100 times. This branch is more interesting, in every
iteration that stays in the loop, iterations where R1 is 0. 1, 2, et cetera,
until 99, this branch is not taken. The BHT is perfectly predicting it,
so we don't access the BTB at all. Only on the last iteration when we are having
the R1 be 99 and we wrap around here and try to compare again, and this
time we see that R1 is 100, and jump out. Is this branch taken?
Because again, we have a perfect BHT, that means that the only time
the BTB is accessed for this instruction is that one last time when
we are jumping out of the loop. So the BTB will be accessed
only once because there is only one time that this branch has actually taken.